et sa naissance c'est vous quand on y
pense avec violence il repouss le lait
que sa nouriss Une F sans malise venu de
Suisse gentiment lui donneré car
le
millionou cur de à condition d'en mettre
les biberons c'était un bébé dionilé
avec des petits mollet mais déjà le
monde l'appelait P le bordel qui P le
bord l'enfant terrible avait l'horreur
morbide de ce liquide que l'on appelle
de l'eau la plus mauvaise estant la
flotte
anglaise à l'aise nous mange del car le
Milon ça vous donne un cœur de lion
qu'il était content de
Napoléon toi tu me plais pour tout ce
que tu as fait moi je te donne la
Bourgogne
[Musique]
le de la cas à la mer des
Antilles
[Musique]
ur
etve
les
[Musique]
je
messieurs mesdames voici la fin du drame
laieu aux armes laiss vos larmes
coulunique le magnifique C
histori mort assassiné
[Musique]
car était le pauvre garçon on lui a
glissé dans son ver de l'au mand il est
Mor der cl le
Bou le B non le band vra
B